I'm like and I created surf set surf set
really started out of necessity I
couldn't get to the ocean I really loved
the way that the body type in the
fitness level that I attained while
surfing so I needed to create a workout
that can mimic that this is your at-home
surf set full-body workout
alright guys so today we've got a full
body agility focused workout so we're
gonna move it around a bit I guess now
we're gonna add a shuffle for a little
bit of cardio in between the plyometric
movements and strength moves okay the
you take as much spaces alright I will
watch alright so you want to get you
give yourself probably about 15 feet
thereabouts
alright depending on how much you want
to how far you want to have to go each
time so first one real basic we're just
gonna shuffle over stop I'm gonna
shuffle back alright now this time we're
gonna shuffle over squat jump we're
gonna do four all right now we're gonna
shuffle back let's go four three two one
now this time we're shuffling back and
we're going right down turkish get-ups
all right so up we can add weight if you
want switch insides shuffling back
Turkish get up again up back down all
right this time shuffle back
five push-ups focusing on that core
shuffle back five push-ups up last one
shuffle over split squat jumps four five
and shuffle split squats I'm tired just
demoing it imagine what you're going
through
shuffle shuffle stay low use that core
alright you go that's it get off the
ground perfect one more back five on
that side go get up there that's it
little lower on the squats
all right back so we'll go to each side
up that's it
there you go
same thing on the other side fast as you
can
now we're shuffling back push-ups right
down go five back five push-ups split
squat jumps coming up come on finish
strong that's it so go to each leg
exploding up last one there shuffle back
to each leg and that's it so to recap we
start off with fifteen seconds of the
shuffle back and forth just to get you
going and then we started with the squat
jumps four reps here shuffle back four
reps over there shuffle over to this
side again with a second thing we add is
the Turkish get ups so you do two per
arm total the four on this side four on
that side shuffle back gonna push ups
five reps on this side shuffle back five
reps on that side shuffle back again and
we do the split squat jumps two per leg
so four on that side pull on that side
and then you repeat that whole thing one
more time very very overall nice
intensive well-rounded workout good work
sir Hank thank you for appreciating make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any other fighting weight episodes